dans les rédactions 'l'annonce n'a pas
fait l'effet d'une bombe
pourtant 47 postes vont être supprimés
au bien public et au journal de saône et
loire sur les 300 existants mais ces
départs se feront sur la base du
volontariat
c'est donc plutôt sereinement que les
syndicalistes se sont rendus au siège du
journal de saône et loire pour
rencontrer la direction
objectif obtenir les meilleures
conditions salariales pour les départs
des postes supprimés sont jugées
inadaptées et en surnombre dans la
conjoncture actuelle détaillé par sept
syndicalistes huit postes à la rédaction
trois postes de journalistes et cinq
postes d'assistante d'âge ans mais
aurait 29 postes aux techniques et 10
postes administratifs va y avoir une
réorganisation au sein des radiations un
emploi au déploiement des forces entre
les deux titres avec un million
d'exemplaires vendus par jour le groupe
ebra qui comprend les deux journaux
bourguignons et leader de la presse
quotidienne régionale en france
pourtant les lecteurs sont de moins en
moins nombreux le groupe de presse doit
donc s'adapter aux nouveaux modes de
consommation de l'information pour
conserver sa notoriété et retrouver une
rentabilité financière
on a lancé un grand projet de
réorganisation du fonctionnement de nos
rédactions avec une très belle ambition
éditoriale pour produire beaucoup plus
de contenu sous toutes ses formes
le journal papier bien entendu mais pas
uniquement aussi du diaporama de la
vidéos des podcasts les négociations sur
la réorganisation des rédactions et les
départs volontaires risque de durer
quelques semaines